không ăn tình đặc lắc buồn khởi tổ bị cân, bắt tạm xam phán dành dương bảo,
năm 2020, chú thị sả ninh hoa, tình khánh hoa và khởi tổ.
Câm đi khỏi nơi cứ chú đối với vợ là hủ thị biết dân, bố mấy bẩy tuổi,
để điều tra về hình vý sản xuất, muốn bán hàng giả là thực phẩm,
cú thị là cà phê bột.
Theo kích quả điều tra ban đầu, chương ngày 20 năm,
lực lượng chức năng phát hiện ông bảo cùng quan trái đang xáu
1,2 mil kilugam cả phê bột không sóu nguồn gốc trong một phụ nữ tại thành phố Buôn mà thuật.
Hám sách hình gấp cơ sở sất của vợ trong bảo tại tình khánh hoa,
công an thu dữ hàng loạt máy móc dùng để giang xây, đong có khả phê bột.
Khóa hai tình huy lửa uống đậu này, đường, chức tạo mầu,
tạo muối, cung mực nghiênstwa trong ninh tư tuổi cả phê bột thành phẩm với tổ của lượng gần một tấn.
Bất trông bảo hai dẫn chỉ xử dụng từ ba đến chính kilugam hặt cafe,
con lại lại đồng nèng cùng các loại phụ ra.
Hỗn hợp này sau khi được dăng xây sẽ tạo ra một trong kilugam
cả phê bột thành phẩm có muối, mầu gần dống thuật.
Tư đầu năm 2019, đường đến nay, họ đã sử dụng 2,5% cafe bột ra,
tư thu tụt tại nhiều tình như bình định, lâm đồng, đặc lắc,
hình vụ án đăng được tiếp tục đưa tra, mở rộng.